امام هذا المنزل المدمر التي حصرته قوات
الاحتلال اثناء تقدمها الى هنا في محيط
مستشفى كمال عدوان تحاول هذه العائله في
هذا المنزل الحصول على ماوى رغم الدمار
الذي حل هنا
بالمنزل والله ه هي قدام اطلاق النار على
الدور وهذه الدار انقص واخذت برضه قذايف
مدفعيه وصواريخ زنانه هي الحيطه هذه
مهدوده حاطت خشب انقصف الدار صامد فيها اه
ه انقصف تقريبا بعد 15 يوم من الحرب البيت
انقصف واحنا ظلينا فيه ما طلعناش منه لما
نخش اجتاحوا عند كمال عدوان صار خطر كثير
غدرنا المكان لما صار انسحاب للجيش
رجعناها وانا زي ما انت شايف حاطت حصر وس
على حل من الشارع صامت في البيت يعني فيش
مكان يعني لو بقوللك بغطيه كله بنيله
ه
فيش مجال اه ويند تروح انا حتى بستنى في
هدن تصير عشان اعمل زينو نرجع ل ايام جداد
يعني ست اخوه احنا سبعه سته والله و حتى
في لي اخو اسير اعتقلوه الجيش استشهدت
الله يرحمها اولاد اخوي اثنين وابوي وابن
عمي من زمان ما
تحمم نساوي طب جيب كمان حطب
بدك
المكان هذا احنا خينا قصفه دار اهلي هنا
وبعدين قصفه دارنا احنا وهي زي ما انت
شايف هذا المربع كان مقاوي 80 نفر 80 نفر
هذا كان مقاوي هي بنك الاهداف هذا بنك
الاهداف الاسرائيليه ما رحن لا غنمه ولا
حتى دابه من دارنا هذه مش راجعين عليها
الا على السبع انشاء المولى اما مش
طالعين ما فيش امام
الا الصمود والتحدي في امامنا غير خيار مش
امكانيه يعني عرا الشعر اما عظماء فوق
الارض او عظما من تحتها بس ها اللي
بنقوله من وسط هذا الدمار تحاول الكثير من
العائلات العوده الى منازلهم لكن حجم
الدمار والخراب كبير لكن لا مفر من العوده
انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه